uh pledges promises call them what you
will is this the start of a new
Manifesto for the labor party
honestly Jay when I arrived here today I
thought am I in a general election
because the music's playing you can see
it's a full uh Atrium a big theater 400
people in the audience and it did really
feel to me and I've done a few of these
uh like the beginning of an election
rally if you like this is what leaders
do when they're gearing up to a general
election but my goodness that general
election is sometime off yet with uh
conservative sources suggesting to me
that it won't come until the Autumn of
2024 but what was kirstarma trying to do
today this is if you like building on
the speech he gave at the end of last
year about Devolution talking about a
decade of renewal and and trying to put
a framework if you like today with these
five missions they will form the basis
of the manifesto I guess the question is
that this is a leader who is 28 points
ahead in the polls but that's the been
driven to be blunt more about this fat
satisfaction with a conservative
government than everyone suddenly liking
the look of Labor people perhaps wanting
change that's what candidates on the
doorstep certainly tell me in MPS but
are they sure about what labor stands
for and I think that there is a risk in
all of this that as kiss Thomas sets out
this Blue Sky Thinking there is perhaps
a disconnect between people's daily
lives and the reality of that and
whether or not he's connecting with
voters